my name is anna yvonne moyo
i am
currently acting executive director at
the center for the study of violence and
reconciliation csvr in short based in
johannesburg south africa
i am a transitional justice expert and
have worked extensively on the african
continent on transitional justice issues
from
addressing colonial era legacies through
transitional justice addressing
socio-economic issues through
transitional justice but also addressing
some of the current and imaging uh
challenges and issues in practice
through transitional justice
thank you so much for taking the time
today to discuss with us
um
maybe before we start with uh with the
with the main topic could you tell us
what is transitional justice
i'm sure there are a lot of people who
don't know what this term
means uh transitional justice uh
basically refers to
a set of measures
that include truth uh reparations um
justice and accountability and
guarantees of non
recurrence of conflict
that are aimed at addressing the
consequences of conflict consequences of
authoritarian rule and other incidents
that bring about across human rights
violations uh and other human rights uh
violations and crimes
a particular setting be it a society a
nation a country or a region
that is the the simpler definition of
transitional justice
on the african continent for instance we
have expanded this definition to really
also include specific tenets of
transformation or transformative justice
so to speak so we are looking at these
measures uh uh including uh formal and
non-formal measures or mechanisms
also including traditional justice
mechanisms to
implemented or
implemented to the ground together with
um formal justice mechanisms to address
consequences of violence consequences of
some of the tendencies and incidents in
africa including legacies of africa's
brutal past uh to ensure that we move
away from uh that
history of brutalization and violations
to economic transformation developmental
justice and transformative justice
and have you used that framework in the
in the
in the context of csvr
to tackle the i mean colonial crimes or
the legacies of colonialism on the
continent or if uh
somewhere else in the world
indeed lillian we are using that
framework to address a number of
occurrences on the continent if you look
at a number of countries on the african
continent some of the
conflicts that we're experiencing
currently really stem from
some of the unresolved issues of the
past the colonial irreligious issues of
land in africa
that has not yet um been redistributed
for instance from the colonial from the
colonial uh um era owners for instance
is one of the
the root causes of conflict in africa
issues of access to resources access to
opportunities for instance access for
instance to development in africa still
very much
is an unresolved issue of the past so we
are using this framework
of addressing the unresolved issues of
the past and the colonial era legacies
through transitional justice to ensure
that we deal with issues of
redistributed justice through
transitional justice we deal with the
issues for instance of addressing some
of the
past issues for instance the high levels
of inequality in a number of african
countries really stem from africa's
unequal past when it comes to
the rights the access and opportunities
that are available for citizens
vis-a-vis those available for instance
for colonial uh masters or colonial era
owners for instance those who colonized
africa in the past so we we have um in
africa where our colonial era owners or
colonial era masters live alongside um
the majority
of africans who are poor who are
uh excluded from the mainstream economic
activity because of the segregation and
the exclusionary laws during colonial
era so how do we address some of those
issues we really need to rethink and
re-look um at some of the issues for
instance the inequalities brought about
by colonialism in africa addressing them
as some of the root causes of the
current conflicts that we experience in
africa some of the tensions we see in a
number of countries for instance uh
really need us to adopt that lens of
addressing some of these issues through
transitional justice
and addressing them from a
redistributive justice lens that is one
of the elements are enshrined in the
african union transitional justice
policy as an element or a pillar of
transitional justice to address some of
these issues coming from africa's brutal
past
can you give us uh concrete examples of
um
of how i mean how you are you are
mobilizing this framework with uh
specific countries
certainly um some countries for instance
like namibia currently
are undertaking
an audit around the land reform agenda
for instance so we are coming in saying
there is a need to use transitional
justice lens to that discussion it
cannot be simply um a matter of uh land
expropriation it has to be it has to be
an issue that is looped or
from a transitional justice lens through
risk uh redistributive justice that i
spoke about how does it look like from a
transitional justice lens how do we
address this as an issue of the past the
unresolved past the colonial era legacy
in namibia for instance that for
instance is causing tensions in the
current uh in the current uh governance
uh
in in namibia so
having a transitional justice lens then
will ensure that we look at land
ownership issues and look at for
instance who were the original owners of
the land prior before colonial colonial
colonization and seeking then to at
least redistribute land equally evenly
amongst the populace of namibia so a
transitional justice look then forces us
not only to look at it from an economic
point of view or from a land ownership
point of view but to really look at who
are the owners in some instances colon
communal lands are belonging to ethnic
groups was taken so some of it really
will require that we redistribute that
land to the original owners and ensure
that that ownership um of the land to
the original sectors is retained
but at the same time addressing the high
levels of inequality in the country
through transitional justice so with
transitional justice we are looking at
addressing or redressing some of the
wrongs the the colonial inner wrongs at
the same time ensuring that we are
transforming and developing the lives of
namibians currently in the current
dispensation ensuring that issues of
equity equitable redistribution of
resources of land and opportunities uh
for agriculture for economic development
and economic empowerment are distributed
evenly across races across um
ethnic groups ethnicity and across the
population the whole population and the
people of namibia
thank you very much and um
uh i guess it's very uh it's very
obvious when you are on a continent when
you can see on uh uh
every day like the different uh ways in
which colonialism is still present and
its legacies is still structuring the
lives of
of the population but what about uh do
you think that we are this framework of
transitional justice could be useful
in tackling the legacies of colonialism
in the in the global north where
um
maybe uh states uh like here in uh in
belgium could be inclined to say
it's something that
which happened in the past and which is
far not
that which is not
uh
which is uh which which belongs to the
past it's not the present anymore so how
uh first of all do you think it's it's
relevant it could be useful and uh
and how could it be done
thank you lillian for that question um
issues of the past
um can never really be buried with the
past which is what for instance
many
uh uh former colonial um
countries will be pushing for to say
it's in the past let's let bygones be
bygones let's move forward but really
the past at least in the african
continent continues to haunt the present
and it also uh threatens the future for
instance because some of those legacies
continue to become to to manifest
themselves as root causes of current
conflicts and current manifestations are
of tensions that lead to conflict that
can easily lead to gross human rights
violations so definitely we need to
revisit the past if you look at a
country uh like germany for instance in
20 2018 germany developed a transitional
justice strategy to deal with the past
uh especially in the african countries
that were former colonies um of germany
again this was um
an acknowledgement by germany uh to um
of the fact that we cannot really bury
the past the past is very much present
the only way we can move forward um and
really begin the development um begin to
give developmental aid to some of these
countries is really by first and
foremost addressing the past because um
even though we may say we are moving
forward collectively but the very
communities the ethnic groups that were
affected by genocide gross human rights
violations uh slavery and many other uh
uh international crimes that happened
during the colonial era are very much
wounded uh they are still uh uh
wounded um the past is not in the past
but still very much alive the
experiences have been passed on
through generations through narration
oral history
you name it so
communities are aware of what happened
and therefore when nothing is being seen
to be done to address or redress
colonial era wrongs or legacies or
crimes then this fuels tensions
amongst those communities especially
where the very same colonial era
masters come in the name of providing
aid providing support and developmental
um
and economic uh support to the very
countries that they um they previously
committed atrocities and and wrong stone
so that easily fuels that tension
especially when now you look at um other
uh tensions for instance and other fault
lines of ethnicity fault lines of uh
political party um and and and and
association amongst others so in as much
as a particular president in the in the
global south may accept that aid but
those who are aggrieved or those who are
affected if they belong to the opposite
ethnic group for instance this tends to
fuel uh
tensions amongst community members and
we have seen some of these tensions are
becoming full-blown conflict or
full-blown um wars in some of the
countries in africa look at anguilla for
instance look at countries um for
instance um that are still now battling
with a lot of um with a lot of uh
instability like gimme did that just hit
a coup recently so these are some of the
fault lines that usually when we don't
address the past then the past continues
to want the present and it threatens the
stability of the future and the the
sustainable peace
that we try to build for future
generations so there is a need to
address the past in order to secure the
present and um uh secure again a future
that is free of violence and also that
um is a transformational and leads to
sustainable peace
so what i would say uh for instance for
countries in the global north uh
especially european countries um europe
for instance developed a transitional
justice policy but what is a big gap in
this policy is addressing issues of the
past so we are having a policy in the
european union that focuses on current
and future uh conflicts without really
addressing issues of the past that in
itself um is a big gap because we cannot
dissociate the past and the current
occurrences of conflict in many african
countries uh from the colonial era rome
so there is a need for a holistic
approach to addressing uh conflicts in
africa that really got back to the past
the the colonial era wrongs the colonial
era legacies that have been unresolved
until now and starting from there in
order to build
a a
culture of non-impunity for those who
committed those wrongs at the time but
also for future uh uh perpetrators of
these crimes in the future whether
they're africans or non-africans and we
are seeing a lot of proliferation for
instance of guns coming from uh europe
coming from um the the global north for
instance so even the current um uh
conflicts for instance do have um a
starting point they do have instigators
and fuelers so the role of the global
north uh can never really be um uh uh um
uh overlooked in the current conflicts
and addressing some of these really has
to go back to the history go back to the
colonial era rooms that were committed
and start addressing them are coming
from the past coming to the present and
then um seeking also to secure and build
a transformative
sustainable peaceful future
um before uh thank you very much it's um
it's fascinating
i was uh
before we started this uh
this recording we were talking about the
uh the technical nightmares uh technical
nightmare uh
when we um
that is uh uh
uh that we uh we face when we bring
those kind of
uh crimes the colonial crimes
into uh uh courts
uh
and um
so do you do we have what are the
constraints of using of using the uh
transitional justice framework because
as you are you have said with our uh
many
uh advantages related to the fact that
we can go uh
we can go
we can
tackle the roots of conflict so i think
in terms of prescription we have more
advantages maybe you can develop on that
point but what are the constraints
uh
what do we
to what extent is it really the way to
which people have to frame or to uh
shape uh their struggles
thank you lillian for that question um
indeed um i have alluded to some of the
the advantages and some of the
the opportunities for transitional
justice to address this one of their
biggest opportunities i think just
before i go into the constraints one of
the opportunities of transitional
justice is that there is a recognition
for instance when we are dealing with
these issues through transitional
justice that we are dealing with an
abnormal situation that therefore calls
for some form of flexibility in terms of
really
um
looking at the the narrower and very
restrictive international law and
international human rights
tenants that call that uh seek to
identify a perpetrator seek to identify
a victim in their form they must be um
the perpetrator must be brought to book
and the the the victim must be retraced
or there must be reparation but within a
transitional justice there are a number
of trade-offs in built
within the system for instance yes
perpetrators have to be identified and
there has to be acknowledgement of of
having committed some wrongs but at the
same time the kind of justice that we
are talking about is not a perfect
justice it is justice that comes with a
number of cutoffs where for instance
sometimes an apology uh can be uh taken
as what is needed to redress for
instance or to satisfy those who are
victims reparation not in the true sense
of um the full measure of what the
victim suffered but as a talking all
as a symbol of acknowledgement so
symbolic preparations are some of the
traitors for instance so it's not your
perfect justice um but it's justice that
comes with trade-offs but that also
acknowledges the experiences of those
who suffered and also the perpetration
of those who may have perpetrated the
atrocities and those coming together
co-existing towards moving forward being
transformed transforming perpetrators
and victims into active citizens who can
live alongside each other who can
partner together
in order to to to to to to build a
sustainable uh uh peaceful future so
some of the constraints of transitional
justice once again um is uh the fact
that um there may not be political will
in most instances from those who are
seen to be perpetrators especially for
colonial iran
are wrongs they may not be the states
who may have perpetrated those
atrocities may not be willing to reopen
the chapter uh to look at what happened
uh begin a process of uh truth seeking
um then identification of perpetrators
acknowledging that indeed wrong wrongs
were committed and seeking to forge
a path together with victims towards
addressing some of these atrocities and
together achieving or rather building
towards achieving sustainable peace
in the long term so there might not be
any political will whatsoever
and transitional justice really relies
on the political will and willingness of
those who perpetrated those atrocities
and the victim or rather the countries
uh uh to whom these wrongs were
committed against so that is the
starting point if this is not there then
any transitional justice talks will
definitely fail because both parties
need to come to the table need to
initiate that conversation
and map out a transitional justice
strategy on how this will be addressed
so that is number one constraint and
this is where uh in most countries even
countries just were without in in the
global south where there is no uh global
north um uh uh uh a perpetrator this is
how many transitional justice processes
fail because of that lack of political
will uh another constraint that i can
bring
with transitional justice once again
um
is just the the issue around um
records because now we are talking about
what happened in the past a colonial era
in many african countries means more
than 50 years
of of these atrocities having been
committed some are committed in the
1900s we are in 2021 so the direct
victims have passed away
so there was no
uh record-keeping at the time so issues
of record-keeping uh to really uh
determine who was a victim uh how they
suffered and all of those things so
archives are not available in many
countries so really it's a word of mouth
or
experiences of victims passed on orally
uh by word of mouth over the uh through
generations so the first-hand narrative
of what happened may not exist uh some
countries have have really done well in
terms of archiving what happened or
keeping a national
collective of what happened in the past
but in many instances for transitional
justice especially when we are looking
at reparations uh a direct uh or rather
individual operations this may not be
enough for instance to secure
direct or individual reparations for
direct victims it may not be enough for
instance to secure
a prosecution for those who may have
committed those atrocities but of course
other international law principles
may kick in that will really help
transitional justice processes for
instance the international law principle
in international human rights that um
even um even in instances where those
who committed atrocities may not be in
government at the time but the the the
the the most uh current governments um
who belong to that specific state
inherit the crimes committed by the
previous government so they can still be
held accountable they can still be uh
taken to court they can still be uh
called to answer or respond to some of
them uh to some of the questions that
may come up around transitional justice
reparations and so forth and they can
make a uh make an apology they can um
pay reparations to victims they can make
symbolic preparations they can come to
the party in terms of acknowledging and
admitting the wrongs that were committed
in the past
thank you very much it's very clear
um you mentioned at some point that we
were building a transitional justice uh
strategy with the african union
so do you think it's more um
uh
i mean on this issue
on the issues of colonial crimes more
relevant
from the perspective of african
countries to work
at the regional level rather than at the
uh
national level or
um
yeah and how how and how this strategic
eu strategy african union is going to be
deployed implement and implement it
thank you for that question so the
african union developed the policy it
was adopted in 2019 and one of the
issues that really it focuses on is
addressing the the the colonial era
legacies in africa
and um
of course the the policy is continental
but um it's it's still applying at a
national level for instance for those
countries that um
that are affected so the policy really
is a guideline for member states
undertaking transitional justice
processes uh so it provides sort of a
menu of um transitional justice options
that a country that is undertaking a tj
process can choose from in order to
address the consequences of past
violations past and present violations
um so
the application is still very much at a
national level although the strategy
really is applicable at a and and and um
exists at a continental level so really
um it's still very much applied at a
continental level but they're definitely
um alternatives of applying it are
regionally especially where some of
conflicts take an original 10 or take a
regional um manifestation for instance
um so those opportunities exist and
in addressing some of the original
concerns or regional manifestations of
conflict uh
some of the regional economic
communities are also now engaging taking
that uh continental transitional justice
policy and developing their own regional
region specific uh transitional justice
policies or strategies to address some
of the regional contextual realities so
it can apply regionally it can also
apply
nationally but um we are seeing a trend
now where there is a regional uh
strategy that really seeks to address
some of the regional realities and
experiences of conflict as we see with
some of these issues like violent
extremism uh there is a regional
connotation to them so a regional
approach is much more preferred than a
national approach that may not really
address or retrace the issues that
affect a specific region or a number of
countries within a region
thank you very much i'm
looking forward to having a discussion
with you with you and the students and
the
uh and the activists because i think you
are you bring
a
a number of a very important
elements that we have to consider
in
[Music]
when we we address or think about the
possibility of pursuing justice
for a colonial um
for colonial crime scenario
in the context of belgium